welcome to dwz sports news my name is
Mellie and we're in Katowice well one of
the biggest eSports events in history is
about to happen over 120,000 people are
expected on site to see their top teams
battling out for glory honor a beautiful
trophy and of course a big chunk of
prize money we're focusing on the
counter strike tournament were in
following one of the top teams the
Swedish fanatic and I would say let's
get in there and check it out
this is a pro feeder all fighting for
some of the finest teams in the world
the Brazilian luminosity Russian team
Navi Swedish favourites magic and the
home turf team polish virtus Pro all
battling it out for the top price of one
hundred thousand dollars before we get
to the playoffs let's have a closer look
on a team's performance during the group
stage in Group A the Brazilian team
luminosity dominated with four wins out
of five matches the Swedish fanatic also
got four wins on her their belt now we
barely managed to qualify with losing
the first two matches and finishing with
three wins in a row in Group B we have
former team solomid australis passing on
with the absolute clean slate in second
place tempest tome our second brazilian
team made it through quarterfinals
virtus pro keeping her fans on the edge
by barely making it out of the group
stage with a nail-biter match where they
managed to kick out the European team
faced those teams i made it through
group stage are now duking it out in a
quarter finals let's see how they
perform Swedish team fanatic climbed the
title last year in Katowice they were
the team of 2015 winning many major
titles but with changing their in-game
leader in November can't phonetic secure
the title again in recent tournament
right la cremes has become one of the
team's best assets
you have a new player and your in-game
leader changed how does the synergy in
the in your team feel I must say that we
have various energy now because Russia
is not so tactical in-game leader and it
works out for the best of us because we
all are like really good individually
and we can just run through maps and
just aim and kill everyone I mean you
always get nervous even if you have
played this game or any like top soccer
player something like you're obviously a
little bit nervous and and it's good for
me because it's fun to play we're about
to face virtus pro in the next match and
I mean that's the team you played quite
often and well what are you expecting
from match of course it's gonna be a
hard match and they're the home turf
teen so when the crowd this rhythm it's
gonna be really hard
the crowd goes wild for local team
virtus pro on paper fanatic is
definitely the favorite but will they
perform with the crowd rooting against
them fanatic dominates on the first map
train with a solid 16-5 result the
Suites continued a winning spree over
the first half of Inferno virtus Pro
felts impress on her seedy side fanatic
steals the show with brilliant scenes
like this one fanatics all of my still
standing with 10 HP takes down task with
this beautiful optional through smoke
bombs eye cream 61 lettuce pro now on
the teesside manages to grab a few
rounds but it's not enough to get back
into the game against the strong
standing for natalie stoll in this last
round the suites easily the founder bomb
spot virtus pro stands no chance fanatic
effortlessly wins the third map 16 8 and
moves on to the semi-finals
you totally dominated virtus pro and the
quarterfinals I mean you kind of
expected it but you did you feel like
it's going to be that smooth no actually
they're a really good team and I mean
every team ranked between minus 10 can
beat any team so I was it a surprise
that we played so good actually because
we had it like one of our best matches
together as a team because our synergy
and our communication was really on
point we are probably the most dynamic
team out there amongst the top teams
many top teams have like one sniper one
lurker and everything I think we we are
more dynamic we JW and all of can both
play the OP really good sometimes all
law clerks sometimes flash flash alert
lurks so the opponent never knows who is
going to be doing what the next match is
going to be the semi-final against us
trolleys and they well they absolutely
dominated in group stage winning every
match they played and I think it's not
going to be that easy as against verge
pro right no because a soulless has been
our kryptonite before but that was what
Allah last line up with pronax but then
we changed promise with Dennis and then
they got a little bit easier because we
played a whole new different style
Danish team australis is considered one
of the top contenders for the title
previously fanatic is often managed to
take down estrelas making a sweets the
favorite in this Scandinavian matchup
despite overpass being one of
Australia's most played maps will see a
very confident fanatic like here JW
takes down device through smoke and
diffuses the bomb fanatics first half as
counter terrorists and 11 for in the
second half fanatics all of myself so
one week to situation with a stunning
performance with this orb standing with
7 HP vs. to preen device or trying to
plant the bomb first one now he has to
plant this bomb here actually pulls the
fake the mine
of course he does it sold off meister
zip Nix now will he even was this trial
is winning cash fanatic wins the third
map 16-7 taking themselves through grand
finals vs luminosity gaming sadly
floundering let's see who the crowd in
Katowice is rooting for who's going to
win the finals oh it's nothing let me
know City they will destroy fanatic who
is your favorite in this one I think
fanatic because they are very strong
they are very strong and all of my
sister is extremely good are you going
to watch a counter-strike finale I don't
like them to say
before heading to the grand final let's
have a closer look at how the playoffs
when luminosity want to nil against Navi
with having to fight hard for the
victory and even taking it to overtime
on the first map so looking at a bracket
it seems like we're in for an epic clash
between fanatic and luminosity let's see
who's going to take out that boy behind
me home the two strongest teams have
made it into the finals of the virus pro
was eliminated Brazilian luminosity has
taken her place as fan favorites they're
spectacular performance in this
tournament has won them the fans support
but will they be able to break fanatics
dominance luminosity starting out strong
and really challenging fanatic for the
first time leading the first half with
12 to it looks like luminosity could
really take the crown but in the last
round fanatics JW out plays phone who
doesn't have a chance to defuse the bomb
in time with switching sites fanatic
gets back into the game and secures
overtime luminosity starts with a bang
tacho solves the one way to situation
with two impressive kills taking his
team a hat
all of my stir evens out the school with
a sake op shot he takes down to of
luminosities players at once
on inferno luminosity first built up a
spectacular lead which fanatic
completely obliterates in the second
half of the map again the two teams take
it to overtime fanatic wins for overtime
rounds and closes the deal I'm falling
goes down and there it is ladies and
gentleman for their take your Intel
Extreme word fanatic it's a
record-breaking six title in a row the
sweets make counter-strike history
champions back-to-back Academy
experience is phenomenal and make no
mistake about it ladies and gentlemen we
crown Katowice champion it's fanatic and
they're considered as the best team of
the world what a grand finale against
luminosity three maps to all the time
situations but it wasn't enough fanatic
took home the trophy the honor glory and
of course price money people thank you
for watching and hope to see you next
time
you